the german government has said it is
giving more than 1 billion euros in
military aid to ukraine the funds are
part of a 2 billion increase in defense
spending announced on friday over half
of that money will go to the european
peace facility an organization which
purchases weapons for ukraine the move
follows heavy criticism of german
chancellor olaf schulz for his hesitancy
to send heavy weapons to ukraine
the military was able to repel russian
forces at the gates of kiev but as dw's
alexandre von naaman reports soldiers
say they had to use weapons made in the
last century
on the move with members of the 114th
brigade part of ukraine's territorial
defense force
we are in metrevka one of the villages
that were in the way of the russian
invaders and their offensive on kiev
convoy was approaching on the street
we were holding our positions at the
neighbouring village and the highway
they came from the left we were told to
reposition to strengthen our line then
the squadron's commander gave the order
to open
fire lawyer that's his nickname shows me
drone footage of the attack the russians
were disoriented he says they didn't
seem to expect resistance they tried to
break through but lawyer with his
soviet-made rocket launcher stood in
their way
if we'd had modern weapons we would have
destroyed them all
but we had to use what we've got
weapons from the last
the
century
forces do not lack enthusiasm or the
courage to fight against all odds but
what they say they need are heavy
weapons as soon as possible as the whole
country braces for a great battle in the
east only better equipped and armed they
say they can repel russian attacks and
prevent more war crimes from happening
many fear the destruction left behind by
russian soldiers around kiev is a grim
omen of what may be in store for the
east
cook is originally from the donetsk
region in eastern ukraine
i have mixed feelings it's hard you feel
pain grief but we are soldiers so we
have to pull ourselves together we must
not show our pain and fear
our children and wives depend on us
and they depend on each other the worst
moment is the one before the battle cook
says but when it starts he adds the fear
is gone
let's bring in dw political
correspondent benjamin alvarez gruber
who is at one of germany's so-called
easter marches for peace here in berlin
benjamin
chancellor schultz is now making this
big
financial concession will this be enough
to silence critics
many say it's important step in the
direction of further supporting ukraine
financially and also what finance
minister christian lindner pledged with
this additional help saying that most of
it will go to ukraine but many critics
will demand two things or will continue
demanding two things on one side the
embargo when it comes to oil and gas
from russia or
sending heavy weapons to ukraine that
germany has not pledged yet
so why is that i mean as you just
mentioned ukraines have repeatedly asked
for heavy weaponry a heavy military
equipment but germany seems to be happy
to pay for weapons but not deliver them
why not
that's right the criticism is mounting
also within the government there was a
delegation that met with ukrainian
officials saying that would what ukraine
needs now are heavy weapons and even
foreign minister analina during a recent
meeting in luxembourg also said that
heavy weapons are needed also implying
that germany should also
also give them but
german chancellor olaf scholz
has said that germany has supported
world support and also will further
support um
ukraine but has not specifically
mentioned
weapons defense minister christina
lambrecht said that that has one reason
that the enemy is also listening and
that if germany is going to supply these
weapons they will not talk about it
now uh and of course
then there is also pressure mounting uh
from the other direction i mean you are
at one of germany's eastern marches uh
it's a political pacifist protest that's
going back to the 1960s anti-nuclear
protests and so forth
do you get the sense that this war in
ukraine is having any impact on this
movement and and how war has been
perceived
it definitely has a huge impact you just
mentioned this was a movement that was
really big in the 1960s 1980s calling
for disarmament especially also nuclear
disarmament but that has changed and
that has
shifted but when we look at these
protests right behind me there's been
criticism because they say that one of
the reasons that this war occurred is
also due to the nato expansion so for
them this
the stance of being peaceful and not
sending weapons and being against the
special fund
for the bundesville has earned criticism
not only by organizers that are
organizing an alternative peace protest
here in berlin with syrian and also with
ukrainian activists calling for weapons
saying that you can also be a pacifist
and call for the end while also
supplying and pledging to supply these
weapons for ukraine and this criticism
has also been from within the government
we had vice chancellor robert habek
saying that these protests should be the
criticism of this protest should be
pointed towards vladimir putin and the
war so we're seeing an incredible a very
interesting shift in german politics not
only when it comes to supplying this
weapon but also on this discourse on
this discussion what it means to be a
pacifist and if just standing by from
the sidelines and seeing how russia
continues to attack ukraine will be will
be enough
to get a peace again with many saying
that if you actually want peace and you
actually want to support ukraine they
need more than just solidarity on social
media they need either this oil and gas
embargo that i mentioned earlier or
delivery of heavy weapons that ukrainian
president vladom volodomir celensky has
repeatedly asked for all right tw
political correspondent benjamin alvarez
gruber there reporting from one of
germany's easter marches a pacifist
political movement in times of a war
with ukraine thank you so much
you